our next speaker is going to be margaret
mitchell hi margaret
hi how are you
i'm
i'm very good so margaret is a
researcher working on ethical ai
currently focused on the in and out of
ethics and from artificial intelligence
development intact
she has published over 50 papers on
natural language generation assistive
technology computer vision and higher ai
ethics and holds multiple patterns in
the areas of conservation generation and
sentiment classification and today she
will talk to us about the values in
machine learning development
so let me put your screen in the stream
and then we'll let you go and read your
talk
it's good everyone can hear me okay oh
even said so in this little preview cool
um
and then to see the comments i can look
maybe on the right side of the screen um
i would be really happy for people to
ask questions as i go
um that said i might get lost in what
i'm doing and miss that someone is
asking a question
uh so i'll try my best
okay so hello uh thank you for having me
um i recently joined hugging face
to work on things like values in ml
development um
so i'm gonna be here i guess a little
bit as a wet blanket but also hopefully
providing
some useful insights
into the development
okay
um
so by now the
machine learning development pipeline is
relatively familiar to people who work
in ai so first you collect data
then you train and test a model you can
add additional post processing such as
selecting among a ranked list or
applying thresholds then evaluating
in order for the model to output an
eventual decision or answer and people
see the output
but before we even begin the process the
data itself encodes a subset of human
perspectives so what people choose to
talk about and how they talk about it
based on their experience
so the idea that a data set can be
unbiased which is one of these sort of
questions that comes up in the
data versus model debates
it's actually both can be biased
and saying that a data set can somehow
be unbiased misunderstands what a data
set is by definition right so a data set
is not everything and all experience for
all of humanity uh in the world ever or
in the universe ever right by definition
it is a slice of all of that it's a
subset it's a snapshot so that means
that it is biased with respect to
everything else in the universe ever
right it's a very limited subset
specifically collected from the world
with all kinds of skews reflecting the
way that people represent themselves
as well as skus in data collection and
annotation
and the way that people talk about the
world um so we see biases um we see
biases like reporting bias which is
selectively sharing only specific kinds
of information
um think about how often people announce
that they're breathing for example right
all these things are happening all the
time we don't describe them we don't
talk about them they sort of go without
saying
and that means we don't see it in the
data right so for to guess
how often people breathe
based on a web crawl we would probably
get it wrong
and we also see effects like racism and
sexism and ableism and nationalism
express expressed throughout um which
reflects just basic human behavior right
so these biases uh then have a ripple
effect throughout the rest of model
development as the training data itself
is the only information that a
supervised machine learning model can
learn can learn from
other kinds of human biases are then
layered on top of this and injected into
model development by the choice of model
the choice of the objective function how
the model is evaluated
these choices persist
in the rest of the model life cycle
so for example there's the default
effect which is going with whatever is
default uh for the model you're
developing and assuming it is
appropriate so this happens in our model
architecture choices
um although you know this talk about
transformers these talks about
transformers are sort of showing what
happens when you move outside of that
default effect which until transformers
were largely you know sort of recurrent
structures
um
but it's also things like our
optimization choices and then this is
even more true in applied product
context where it's used in different
kinds of context
and there's a similar effect of
anchoring bias which is sticking with
what one is familiar with so think of
what your loss function is right we
don't tend to think a lot about that
unless we're specifically writing a
paper on that
and human biases are further injected
into any post-processing decisions or a
lack of post-processing right so just
because you don't think about it doesn't
mean that something isn't happening it
just means that you are
making the choice to have whatever is in
there as a bias persist as a bias
and this is also where things like
congruence bias comes in
confirmation biases um both are biases
where you tend to pay attention to
outcomes that are familiar to you and
leave out outcomes that aren't so that
means we need to do additional work in
development to think through the ways
that the model can affect different
people and this is a place where risk
harms analysis is really key
um and finally once a model is deployed
people see the output and begin to act
on that output um but it's not the end
of the ml life cycle right so as people
act
on the output um in the outlets where
the data is collected so think about
content moderation that you see on
youtube on facebook
that you know the recommendation systems
you see um in so many of the uh
different apps we use um that then that
creates more data as we interact with
those systems
and then that becomes training data for
an updated model
basically encoding
all of these biases
essentially permanently right so this
creates an echo chamber feedback loop
where the model then learns from the
data that has already encoded the biases
in the first model decisions and so this
can amplify problematic decisions over
time
um i like i like to refer to this as
bias laundering
where the final model can have all kinds
of ethical issues and it can be
difficult to pinpoint the exact sources
that that cause them
although it can be hard
it is part and parcel of the model uh so
really important to actually model and
factor in
um i like to call this bias laundering
also because it allows me to use this
gif it is one of the only gifts i had
made by myself and i'm very proud of it
um
i just read that when women make jokes
in talks it reflects poorly on them so
uh
i guess i'm reflecting poorly to
everyone apologies okay so the input
data set defines what we care about for
the model
uh the default approach to development
is to simply use the training data that
is available in a specific data set and
to evaluate on the evaluation data that
is available in that data set right so
if critical aspects of the problem space
aren't represented in the pipeline then
deploying the model means you are making
the value judgment that these aspects
should not be represented so if the data
the training the post-processing creates
models that disproportionately under
perform on some populations you are
implicitly making the value judgment
that some populations should receive
worse performance right so machine
learning development isn't value neutral
you can just
uh for lack of a better word be ignorant
about those values in your development
and what this means is that we have to
think critically about values encoded
throughout development if our goal is to
in is to advance more human aligned more
ethics-informed kinds of artificial
intelligence
um so this brings us to the role of
ethics in ai and the role of values so
ethics doesn't provide an answer
but rather it provides frameworks for
analyzing problems
in light of different human values
so
some example human values are shown on
the right
and these are exactly the values that
can be incorporated not only within the
development pipeline
but within the development culture more
broadly so having a basic understanding
of the major ethical theories will help
us in learning how to articulate and
justify our decisions so let's dive a
bit more deeply into the ethical
theories that can drive the production
of ai systems
so broadly speaking there are four main
families of ethics
meta ethics and descriptive ethics are
concerned with uh analyses of ethics in
and of itself
uh normative is concerned with the norms
the standards the criteria that define
principles of ethical behavior
these are what provide the tools for
ethical analyses and development
and applied ethics are
essentially ethical theories realized in
practice and within ethics uh informed
development in a technology company this
would correspond to something like the
organizational ethics or the
organization's principles
one of the key ideas here is that we all
have different senses of morality we
have different cultures and religions
that prioritize different kinds of
values
uh so for example
respect and honor for family uh tends to
be relatively underrepresented in
western philosophy
but when we're working within an
organization these values need to be
defined at the organization level in
order to provide a common ground of
values that employees can build off of
and base uh different decisions on so
there's often this question of whose
ethics right like it's so hard to decide
there has to be one and it has to be one
that we all agree on but that's not
right the question of whose ethics is
simply it's the organization's ethics
and every organization will be different
you can think of this as a business
differentiator or maybe a grad school
differentiator or whatever it is
um
and these ethics these values can be
defined by calling together the values
from all different sources
um including all the people who have
been hired right um
so uh there is not one good ethics
there's not one way to say this is
ethical and this is not it's all a
function of the people there and what
the values they prioritize are
all right i hope that makes sense
um so as a vehicle for
operationalizing ethics uh within a
larger development pipeline or within an
organization
normative ethics in particular
provides several different perspectives
so at a high level um these perce these
perspectives concern standards of
criteria
um there are three main theories um i'm
probably doing a horrible job i'm not an
ethicist by training but i've very much
tried to learn ethics uh within ai um so
these are things like virtue
consequentialism uh deontological ethics
um and in the context of ethics informed
organizational processes
uh we're largely following a
deontological ethics that has been
informed by
virtue ethics and consequentialism
so let's turn again to our pipeline
where we earlier highlighted how
different problematic behavior can be
propagated and amplified in a model
and
in the collection of data this first bit
um values of concern include copyright
consent
fair pay diversity and the right to
something like contestation the right to
say that you don't want to be in the
data
um
currently the state of the art on all of
this is terrible
so generally copyright
is not a large part of what's taken into
account during
uh data development consent is
largely absent at least the sort of
informed consent that we would want uh
for people whose data is being used for
training models uh fair pay often it's
no pay so you know that sucks um and we
generally fail at diversity in part
because the culture around machine
learning looks to get annotations as if
the production of annotations is some
black box where you throw in what you
want annotated and you get it back
ignoring that everything that happens in
that process
brings with it tons of different uh
biases and what countries this is
happening in is really going to affect
what kinds of annotations you're going
to get
okay um and then in model training
values of concern include how
appropriate different decisions are in
light of the foreseeable effects of the
model right so you have to think about
how this will be used in context will
these people know what a decision
threshold is and how to change it based
on what they want to do
usually not
and so it's very critical to think
through how these models will be applied
in practice
and in post-processing
values include the consideration of
trade-offs and aiming towards fairness
of outcomes
so we can now further examine what these
ethical values mean uh within this first
data stage
um and i would say defining values in
data collection and annotation is one of
the most pressing issues in technology
currently and questions of who owns the
data whether it can be deleted what sort
of profit or benefit can be derived from
it all come into play
and i like to call this the data
bottleneck because it's a touch point of
information flow
from human thought to ai
but it's the source of an incredible
amount of issues
so in particular there is not a way to
have something like the most values
right or the most ethical thing there
are trade-offs and tensions in all
decisions and so it goes back to the
organizations uh or the individuals uh
maybe if you're working alone um
what your defined values are um and pri
what your prioritization is among them
um so for example we may want to release
a data set to help with benchmarking and
reproducibility
but this comes with the trade-offs of
lack of informed consent
perpetuating problematic ideas that um
that are there without consent um and
the fact that the data can't
realistically but be deleted yet we
don't yet have a state of the art where
we can remove data
this means details of individuals in the
data can not only be shared but
continually amplified and proliferated
without their consent right there's this
sort of misunderstanding that well if
it's out there it's already public so we
can use it the problem is one instance
being public and sort of generally
difficult to access
is different than being uh spread all
over the world to hundreds and thousands
of people these two things are not the
same um and so you know in the effort uh
in the effort to have benchmarking and
reproducibility we're often making the
choice to amplify and proliferate
problematic content without consent
um we may also want to aim for things
like inclusion and diversity within our
data
representing different people with
respect to their different norms
and
but this comes up against things like
exploitation
and tokenism and stereotyping
that's when data is collected with a
specific goal of diversity by ignoring
sort of all the other factors at play
um it's not yet clear what the best
methods are
um
but there's still a lot of work to be
done and at least doing somewhat better
so i'll give you an example um a couple
years ago google was working on face
verification phone unlock um
for the pixel and hired a vendor because
they needed more photos of black people
so what did the vendors do they went to
a homeless camp in atlanta
and paid people there who were black
five dollars
for their face
to build google's diverse uh facial
recognition system that you know
obviously they would make a lot of
profit from so a few issues there one is
equating black people with homeless
people um so that's some sort of
disgusting stereotype i don't think i
was even aware of but there you go uh
exploiting people obviously five dollars
and without uh very informed consent
um
and also tokenism where you're not
looking at how to include this person in
light of what their general life is like
their culture everything else like this
but actually just focusing on who you
could quickly get because of this single
characteristic that's tokenism
right so one of the key solutions to
operationalizing ethical data
development means defining values and
priorities upfront and constructing data
specifically based on the values
so this massively expands what it means
to collect and work with data making
data collection itself a detailed and
nuanced process
with dedicated roles to handle different
aspects of data development and
corresponding artifacts that allow the
values encoded in data selection to be
further examined throughout the pipeline
and then within final release decisions
so this can be seen as a life cycle for
the data as a whole
as it requires continual monitoring and
analyses of the effects of the data and
updates then based on these analyses
um now we can turn to the details of
memory
if you can just interpret one second
we have a question that's very relevant
on the data
and which is how do we push for
adaptation of more ethical data sets and
not imaginate cc4 leon for example in
major conferences
yeah so obvious maybe not obviously so a
lot of researchers
um have increasingly been paying
attention and a subset of researchers
have been publishing papers on this so
uh abeba berhane has done incredible
work on this uh jessie dodge has led
some amazing work on this for um
c4 right so the fact that these papers
are starting to get accepted is a
massive step forward in sort of this
general understanding um they were not
they were largely rejected you know two
years ago uh so there's been an increase
already and understanding why these
things are important uh in part because
of you know the small subset of reachers
really researchers really crying out for
it over and over again
um and making it clear via not only
papers but twitter and blog posts and
interviews and you know so this is sort
of happening now the key now is to make
sure that reviewing rubric
actually cares about this stuff
so uh when you're reading a paper that
talks about model training and model
evaluation you have to know critical
aspects of what that data set for
training is what that data set for
evaluation is and if it's too much to
include in the paper you can have it in
the appendix whatever it is but while we
continue to
you know really celebrate papers that
don't discuss the data they're using at
all we're not going to be incentivizing
ethical data practices
um so reviewing rubric also awards i
have this i have this idea that you can
get an award at a conference for like
best evaluation uh or like best analysis
of input data or something like that
currently we have best paper awards uh
which are it's pretty underspecified and
tends to uh bias in in certain ways but
once we can start breaking this down
into what we really want
uh both in terms of reviewing rubric and
awards then i think we can really get
somewhere
thanks a lot that makes sense
um
cool
um i didn't see the question so i guess
i'm not like in the right chat or
whatever but
cool
um so uh the next bit here in this
model sort of pipeline is the model
training
and that's where values
come into play around the
appropriateness of the loss function
and the model
so
okay
so i'm gonna talk about this via a case
study um i was able to work on
uh coronavirus forecasting um which was
you know amazing to be able to work on
um
and we quickly found that there
were a mass amount of model based
decisions that could drastically affect
people when the model was deployed so
um if you're not technical bear with me
i'm going to try and explain if you are
this might be just a repeat um but this
is very important so false positives in
a coronavirus forecast a model means
that hospitals might be over equipped
expecting a need for more beds and
ventilators but a false negative
means that there would be less resources
than needed which could end in death
right so there are trade-offs in
different kinds of errors but arguably a
model that tends towards false positives
is preferable to a model that tends
towards false negatives
and one of the issues at play
is the choice of loss function
so if you take a look at the different
kinds of objectives that can be used
which are on the um
bottom left
um they treat positive and negative
instances the same way
these are all measured in terms of
absolute values right and so that means
positive false positive false negative
these basic ideas
are to treat it as equivalent
and so for the value-aligned goals of
the model this suggests that some
additional work may be necessary for the
selection of the most suitable model
um and
perhaps unsurprisingly trying to bring
this forward at google mostly meant
hostility and it was a terrible
experience now i'm telling all of you
still important even if people are mean
okay so moving on we come to the
post-processing and final evaluation and
so here too it's critical to think
through
different types of outputs and errors in
order to select the most suitable
metrics to measure model performance
and it's in this stage that concepts
like fairness diversity and inclusion
are really important um some of these
are more developed than others so let's
talk about them a bit
um
so for those of you who are not deeply
familiar with fairness
um one of the most basic ways to think
about fairness
is in terms of a confusion matrix so
what we have here um are
a two byte is a two by two of references
the ground truth the thing that's
actually there
and model predictions the thing that the
model is guessing
um when something exists and it's
predicted that's a true positive
when something doesn't exist and it's
not predicted that's a true negative
the error types we really care about
when we're talking about fairness
are false positives and false negatives
so these falses right so if it doesn't
exist
but it is predicted that's a false
positive uh if it exists and it's not
predicted that's a false negative
um
but in one case a false meg a false
negative may be better than a false
positive and in another case a false
positive might be better than a false
negative
um so it's very critical to
to define
what kind of fairness you care about
as the equality of essentially false
negatives across different groups
equality of essentially false positives
across different groups when you have
these equalities based on these kinds of
errors this is what we mean when we talk
about fairness
um so a case where false positives would
be better than false negatives is
something like privacy and images um so
a false positive here something gets
blurred um that shouldn't be blurred
that's just sort of usually a bummer
but a false negative could be something
that that needs to be blurred not
getting blurred so that's like identity
theft
so we clearly have
a decision to make in our model
development which kind of errors we want
to focus on um and by thinking through
in context it's clear that in a
situation like this we want to make sure
to minimize false negatives
um
false negatives can be better than false
positives uh in something like spam
filtering uh so here in email that spam
is not caught so you just see it in your
inbox
usually that's just a bit annoying
um a false positive email flag the spam
is removed from your inbox so if it's
from a friend or a loved one or it's a
job opportunity
that's a loss right but note that the
usage in context really really matters
here so if foreseeable users
include those that are easily scammed
leading to a loss of wealth then false
negatives have a greater risk and model
development needs to balance these
different populations in determining the
optimal models the current state of the
art
nothing
so
low hanging fruit we can do a lot better
um okay cool
um so finally uh people see the output
uh in this process and uh it begins
again as people interact with this
output and then the biases are further
encoded uh and more deeply ingrained in
the model
um
i'm not sure how i am on time because i
started a little early
um i can go
you have time if you
yeah so i wanna have time for questions
um
i have questions right now if you want i
can ask i have a few questions right now
yeah yeah what i'll do is i'll just kind
of like wrap this up really quickly um
and then we can go to questions um
yeah so here's some basic steps forward
um and this is sort of what i would like
you guys to remember if you take
anything from this talk
um so uh we need to align considerations
of our own values to this larger group
that we're working in these stated
values
thinking through
uh if the technology should exist at all
by using this sort of analysis of
foreseeable harms and risks
by the expected populations by the
people who will be affected by the model
and how it will be used in context
establishing basic organ organizational
values can be informed by things like
virtue ethics
consequentialism deontological ethics
where things like privacy fairness
justice consent all these things come
into play and then can inform you know
what we prioritize as we develop
um
once we start establishing these things
as intentional processes throughout the
pipeline requiring artifacts and
documentation
we can start to be able to foresee
uh even more potentially problematic
outcomes and make more informed
decisions on releases
um
this goes to the question uh earlier one
of the critical ways to make this move
forward is
incentivizing ethics and form
development
so this is things like what gets uh put
in review rubric what kind of awards we
get um what sorts of things um are
rewarded when they're talked about
um and one method i've worked on to
capture much of this uh is model cards
um a large part of why i joined hugging
face is because they were trying to come
up with
ways to scale model cards and i thought
i could help
but it's essentially an artifact to
report sort of all of the above
[Music]
and finally throughout uh the critical
critical most serious thing that you can
do
is encourage and reward foresight
thinking through the outcomes with
different people in different contexts
and here's here's what's important to
know some people are good at this and
some people are bad at this so if you're
bad at this don't say we can't develop
ai with foresight just accept that maybe
some people have a strength in this and
you don't right um i've been corrected
that instead of foresight uh what's more
important is rapid hindsight
no some people are good at foresight let
them
stop you from having the need for rapid
hindsight right um so this requires
placing people in the appropriate roles
to make this aspect of development
really shine
okay thank you i'm done i appreciate it
thanks a lot for your talk meg it was
very insightful
um
so i have a few questions that were
asked on the forum let me pick the first
one
so how do we process or do we protect
ourselves against machine learning
system design primarily without ethics
in mind because
we are
obviously
algorithm being run out in the world
right now and uh yeah
yeah
i mean
this is a really hard thing to answer
um i previously thought that part of the
solution was to
make sure that
the development that has already taken
place
uh is retrofitted as much as possible so
taking a look at the kinds of evaluation
data sets that were used the kinds of
training data sets that were used doing
a more further analysis into what errors
it makes and then essentially fine
tuning updating the model based on that
um unfortunately i think in part because
of this issue where a lot of people in
ml and ml are just not that great at
foresight uh and don't really see the
point of it
um we we're gonna need regulation
and so that's that's sort of what it i
think it comes down to at this point
it makes sense
um another question that was a bit too
long so i'm going to read the the last
part from the forum so model
transparency seems to be a question a
precondition of the mentioned ethical
goals dr mitchell seems to emphasize the
role of input data isn't the model's way
of decision making equally important
future importance etc for ethical ai
um
be
equally important
um
i would say all of them above is
important i'm not sure how to extract
that to numerical values to to say that
it's that it's equality
um but uh one of the reasons why i do
have a focus on transparency is because
it's incentivization of good practices
throughout right so if you have to
report uh how your model does with all
these errors then you're probably not
going to release it unless it does well
so as soon as you have transparency this
is a way to essentially incentivize good
practices throughout um input data i do
have a focus on in particular because it
tends because it's what the model knows
it's it's the the model's knowledge
source um so there's so much that can be
said about evaluation and all these
other things but the issues very much
start um with
uh what what's in the data um so i would
say that's that's the highest priority
yeah
and then speaking of data
what about retraining models that are
already trained on energy called data is
it possible to fix them somehow
yeah
so
i mean by unethical data i'm taking that
to mean
uh you know data that that has a lack of
consent data that our licenses and
copyrights are not being paid attention
to data with pii um so i'll assume uh
that's what you mean by unethical data
um i do think it makes a lot of sense to
to retrain and fine-tune and actually
some of the work that i've done um has
been specifically on on bias mitigation
techniques and identification of
stereotypes and things like this
whether it's sort of ethical to retrain
um
i guess that's better than not
retraining if it's going to be deployed
so i guess it depends on the context
that you're in
if you're writing a thesis maybe this
will become your topic of how to start
from scratch if you're in an
organization and you're retrofitting
maybe the best way is to to retrain or
fine-tune a bit um so i think it depends
a little bit on on context um
yeah i guess that's that's the sort of
most relevant answer i have to that
okay there are lots of questions about
the biasing like i have another one here
while training the pretend model is it
possible to add a step including the
biasing algorithm there are emerging
algorithms today could this make some
interesting bias disappear
um yeah
so
so there's a lot of work to be done in
data that has tend to be not
incentivized there's also a lot of work
to be done in models and this and this
has been more incentivized um and so i
just want to make clear i guess that one
of the cool tricks is around uh sort of
multitask learning um so
uh bias mitigation techniques that that
tend to work um you know reasonably well
have to do with predicting a few things
at once
and then uh discouraging one thing while
encouraging another so for example say
that you're trying to predict whether or
not
someone should get promoted
at the same time you can predict gender
and if you find that the promotion
decision
is predictable via the gender then you
know that you have a bias system that's
biased for gender so one of the
adversarial mitigation techniques um
that you know that's pretty fun and
there's a couple papers on this
um i wrote one uh alex beutel uh led a
really cool paper on this is you
essentially um invert the gradient so
you predict both and for everything it's
learning about gender you say the
opposite of that you essentially
multiply by negative one and back back
propagate right so that says like you
don't know what gender is you and you
just tell the model until it's
essentially random um and that's really
a cool way of sort of removing a gender
bias there's other things you can do
with like pairing um but but a lot of
the key techniques are around
uh just this like having
two or more things that you're modeling
at once and encouraging one while
discouraging another
that's a very cool technique indeed
um
another question let me scroll a little
bit
uh yeah there might not be a magical
solution but what's the easiest way to
determine whether a text generation
model is not racist or sexist and how do
we solve this quickly without losing too
much of training data
it quickly huh yeah
yeah i mean obviously as quickly as
possible is good if there's sexist and
racist things in the world so you know
fair enough
um
so i think that it's i don't know that
it'll ever be possible to have a model
that's not sexist or not racist because
i don't know that it's ever possible to
have a person who's not sexist or racist
right i mean these are all sort of based
on heuristics and how our brains work as
as we're brought up and so um part of
you know going through like ally
training and you know these kinds of
things means that you have to recognize
it and uh proactively address the kind
of patterns that you tend to do um so
you would imagine that similarly for a
model you would put in place normative
constraints like you do with people uh
so that means saying that um you know we
are going to mask gender so there's no
distinction between gender when we're
training our toxicity model and so when
we have an input gender we we have no no
way of handling we don't know what it is
right um and so so we won't correlate
the two and toxicity um actually
like particularly has a bias towards the
term gay and lgbtq terms
um so there are things you can do like
masking those or adding more data anywho
um
the point here is that um we can put in
place specific normative constraints
based on our social
knowledge so this is where social
scientists come in sociologists come in
on how racism and sexism and things like
this are expressed
so we can do that and that's definitely
like a quick fix
um but a full-on fix might might not be
possible um but you know yeah do is do
as much as you can definitely
another question around
the bias and data is how could we
balance the filtering of bias between
freedom of speech and offensive biased
consent oh that's such a good question
yeah i've been struggling with this
because
ideally we can ground ai development in
like fundamental rights or human rights
um but if you are american-centric then
freedom of speech is like you consider
that like a fundamental right right but
like in other places uh like uh privacy
is nice or like you can imagine freedom
from discrimination as to be a cool
thing um or perhaps a basic right that
people should have uh but that you know
comes in conflict with the with a free
speech thing
um so i mean i think part of the issue
here is that when you say free speech um
there's there tends to be an assumption
that there is some sort of uniform
sampling over all data instances so that
free speech as a whole is is reflected
so you have like people talking about
women positively and people talking
about women negatively and so it's all
free speech we want it all um but what
in fact happens is that um the data sets
tend to be heavily biased towards men
and using um
and using sources where there's misogyny
so like reddit um
and that is not counteracted by free
speech about uh women being awesome or
whatever uh so um
so yeah i mean like one of the things
about free speech that that is kind of
fun to do is actually data collection so
i was part of a project uh called
project respect that went to like gay
pride parades and and had people say
like really proud things about their
identity and their uh you know uh their
lgbtq like associations and stuff like
that and that created like tons of data
that we can use in training a toxicity
model um that's a lot of work and you
have to have willing participants and
hopefully compensate them whatever they
should be paid
um but um
but yeah i mean it's there's a few
things you can do but keep in mind that
the free speech idea
is a little bit hampered by the fact
that the free speech that we collect is
is biased and tends to be more
misogynistic and racist than maybe a
larger sample would have
yeah
definitely
and around like the
compensating participant for creating
the data i have another question which
is is making it mandatory and forcing to
create data sets where each participant
is highly paid going to put a lot of
pressure on researchers from low
resource institutions and researchers
from law resources countries
yeah that's a really good question
um i think this is where things like
governments start to play a role um
and
it's it's i think it's also kind of
important to note that this also is very
destructive to private companies that
are um that have you know a lot of money
so
um it's sort of like i sort of feel like
the larger the organization the more
this will hurt them right so if um for
example you require google to pay
everyone for the data they're producing
um google you know google's business
model would be basically destroyed um so
you know in some ways we might think of
methods where different compensation
tiers you know make make sense for
different kinds of organizations you
could get this via regulation so you
know if you're a grad student um
paying you know
a minimum wage or whatever for your
annotations um that's that's pretty
reasonable that's pretty normal um if
you're you know a multi-billion dollar
corporation um perhaps paying a lot more
is is worthwhile uh especially because
like you're making profit off of this so
it should be
a percentage of that profit in some way
um so i think there are ways not to over
disadvantage um uh low resource uh
groups
um or or organizations um and i think
that it could go the other way like very
much harming larger private companies
and one last question which is a bit
more personal is what does the regular
day-to-day work look like for you
oh well so i just joined hugging face
full time on november 1st
um and before that i was doing like a
lot of contracting and consulting and so
i've just been sort of all over the
place i'm someone who wears many hats
like i like talking about philosophy and
then i like talking about statistics and
then i like coding and then i like
writing and
uh so i really don't think i have a
traditional day
uh i will say that i hate waking up
before 9 00 a.m pacific time
and so presenting at 9 30 was a feat
i hope i seemed coherent
um i think that's that's basically the
only the only standard throughout my day
the only common thing is that i try and
not get up until nine um but other than
that yeah i jump around between coding
and thinking through math stuff and
writing papers and reading papers and
sometimes answering email
i'm like
well thanks a lot for your time this
morning because it was a super
interesting talk and very insightful
answers to all the questions
awesome thank you guys